[Music]
well the first thing I want to do is
thank you a few days ago somehow the Y
files hit a million subscribers and that
is something that I never expected yeah
I would have lost that bit I know it was
very unlikely oh it sure was I just said
it was Lord think about it you got no
background in any of the stuff you talk
about your middle age so everyone
younger than 30 thinks you're an idiot
journalism training the fact that anyone
watches the show is nothing short of a
miracle gee thanks for the vote of
confidence what I'm just telling it like
it is yeah but you don't have to be so
condescending about it
foreign
it all started in 2020 we were living in
LA and running a successful studio
called betterbox we had a big audience
popular podcast and a great location on
Sunset Boulevard well hold on what is
this some kind of retrospective this is
the y-files origin story oh this is
gonna be painful
here we are live better Box Studios kill
Tony the number one
formerly the number one live podcast in
the world
foreign
[Music]
was we weren't making any money podcasts
don't make money yeah well we didn't
know that at the time so we decided we'd
go out and pitch investors so factoring
our huge audience ideal Hollywood
location and Freddie Prince Jr huge
audience ideal Hollywood location and
Freddie Prince Jr we truly believe that
better box is well positioned to be the
premier comedy production company in the
industry thank you
so I think we're ready to pitch once we
service
guys Ken we actually had some investors
interested a couple of big agencies too
but then we hit a snack a snag wait wait
wait when were you pitching investors
well this video we're watching was shot
in April 2020. oh no yeah something
happened that we didn't see coming
something that nobody saw coming
you might want to put on the news okay
what channel doesn't matter
the golden state is in shutdown mode
that requires of this moment that we
direct a Statewide order for people to
stay at home how are we supposed to
pitch investors during a pandemic this
is a moment we need to make tough
decisions
[Music]
hey I can't hear him can you hear him no
a little louder
very good oh yeah
hang on a sec with our huge audience and
our celebrities
maybe the deck speaks for itself what
are you saying what do you think maybe
we don't need words
maybe we don't need words what are you
an idiot what it's an idea I think it's
positive I'm positive you're an idiot
songs
we need words okay
okay Gino next slide
oh dear God
so we tried to make the best of it and
Pitch anyway now at this point it's late
May 2020 and we actually have some
investor meetings but you remember how
meetings were back then the
entertainment industry is built on
intellectual
gauge seriously
sorry sorry that's my fault
it's fine
where were we oh yeah
this is a joke hello
can you hear me can you change my
settings no somewhere no that's not what
she was saying La was a ghost town but
we tried to make the best of it from the
prison ah damn it what are you doing I
have an itch no I could do it now I
could just shoot left left
anything
okay
so yeah it didn't work
even though we had some great meetings
investors told us the same thing they're
interested but before they put money
into something they wanted to wait until
the lockdown was over two weeks to
flatten the curb huh right so Nick how
are people there coping with these these
new ground rules uh transformational
ones
I've got to say Aaron it's strange most
of us have been living under this kind
of stay at home thing all week the
schools have been closed but I must say
now that there is an order out there now
that we're being told to do it it does
feel different more restricting I just
want to give you a quick
but as we got into the summer the
situation in La somehow got worse
[Music]
so after 20 years in the City of Angels
Jen and I moved to Scottsdale Arizona
[Music]
when I decided I wanted to start a
YouTube channel it would be about
science Mysteries and conspiracies but
we'd keep it lighthearted and fun and
I'd have a wacky co-host yes truly and
that's when nerdy sexy cool was born oh
wait nerdy what nerdy sexy cool my
YouTube channel nerdy sexy cool I'm more
like nerdy cringy cool thank you for
watching nerdy sexy cool where we talk
about the stuff that you didn't learn in
school if you're digging our Vibe please
click like And subscribe but when
posting in the comments please don't be
a tune
foreign
I can't take it oh you'd rather have a
ukulele no no
but Science History biology and
conspiracy theories too if you want to
learn in a light-hearted way just click
like And subscribe today we might be
right we might be wrong but you can
still sing along nerdy sexy cool nerdy
sexy cool loved by everyone from
brainiacs to fools so I had the name of
the channel got all this branding and
was ready to get started but then it
turned out the name nerdy sexy cool was
taken oh you didn't check that first no
I didn't think of that well you touched
a bullet yeah I did and Jen came up with
the name the y-files which was awesome
on several levels so it was time to get
to work
I'm going to do something that's never
been done before ever in history and you
are going to witness it ready now I knew
this channel was gonna work my thinking
was I've been a professional writer
producer editor and host so how hard
could it be simple basket yeah turned
out it was much harder than I thought I
put up my first video Welcome to the
y-files where smart folks like us get
together to talk nerdy and nobody
watched and today we're talking about
math facts and I have no idea why with
this high production quality what is
that what is what you look like a
one-man boy band who got old but I stuck
with it and slowly over time and many
many mistakes the videos got better
I eventually found a format that worked
and people started watching just not
very many people on the first
anniversary of the channel we had 5 000
subscribers and these 5 000 people were
the best they supported everything I did
and if you're one of those subscribers I
can't thank you enough but if the
channel was going to survive 5 000
subscribers a year wasn't gonna work at
this point Jen and I were living off
savings I kept posting videos and it
wasn't working but then we got some luck
people started watching no oh Jen got a
job as Chief Operating Officer of a big
animation company explosive you might
know them as Cyanide and Happiness
yeah I know these but this job was in
Texas so we packed up again
[Music]
over the next few months the channel
continued to grow not quickly but
steadily by April 2022 we were at about
15 000 subscribers and videos were
getting about 5 000 views in total we
weren't blowing the doors off but I felt
like the channel had real potential by
May 2022 my brother Gino had been
nagging me for months to upload short
videos to tick tock I always thought
Tick Tock was a stupid idea unless
you're the Chinese government right but
the channel was still growing so slowly
that I needed to try something I created
a couple of short videos about
coincidences and uploaded them to tick
tock within a few days I had 50 000
subscribers and 2 million views on Tick
Tock well I know I was excited and
annoyed I didn't want to create short
videos but people were coming over from
Tick Tock to find the main Channel and
we started picking up a few hundred
subscribers a day rather than a few
dozen which is what we were averaging
for two years and then Tick Tock Shadow
Banned Me so the subscribers stopped but
now I had a bunch of short videos and
YouTube shorts was just spinning up I
had nothing to lose so I uploaded them
to YouTube and and nothing ah for a
couple of weeks then something happened
the YouTube algorithm picked up the
short video about the coincidences
between JFK and Abraham Lincoln yeah
that is a good one yeah I like it too we
got a few thousand subscribers in a day
then the algorithm started pushing our
other shorts about coincidences we
started May with 25 000 subscribers and
ended May with a hundred and sixty
thousand
yeah it was amazing problem was nobody
was watching the main videos all the new
subscribers were teenagers not teenagers
I know they don't watch anything longer
than 60 seconds and the comments they
leave they're just awful so I had a nice
base of subscribers but the views were
still low and here's some inside
baseball about YouTube it doesn't matter
how many subscribers you have that's a
vanity number what matters to the
algorithm and the sponsors is views and
I wasn't getting any views it was
frustrating
then a viewer left a comment on one of
my videos and I wish I could remember
his name and if I find it I need to give
him a shout out he recommended that I
Live premiere videos since I was posting
at the same time every week he said it
would be a fun way to engage with the
audience so in preparation for our first
Live premiere I produced a video that I
thought would appeal to everyone to the
science nerds the conspiracy crowd and
the Mystery fans simulation Theory and
to this day it's one of my favorite
episodes Mueller's experiment showed is
that even though the electrons started
as waves but behaves like particles
after being observed at the moment the
decision to observe them was made the
electrons recorded themselves as having
passed through the slits as particles
the electrons change their state by
going back in time back in time
folks this is this is just staggering
stuff
again I become obsessed with this idea
by the way that's the Y files uh that
was a YouTube video uh it's really
amazing it got about 5 000 views the
first day and that was a lot for the
channel now keep in mind when simulation
Theory came out we had 250 000
subscribers yet 5 000 views was a good
day so all those subscribers they
weren't watching but there were 150
people in the Live premiere I couldn't
believe it so simulation Theory kept
performing well and I followed it up
with the whole to Hell video which also
did well in the meanwhile I kept pumping
Out YouTube shorts I hated doing them I
still do but I kept at it Circleville
letters was next it didn't perform that
well but it was still well written and
well produced and it brought in True
Crime fans then we premiered operation
high jump the story about the UFOs in
Antarctica that got 50 000 views in the
first day that was bananas and that was
July we got 150 000 subscribers that
month and YouTube finally started
pushing the long form videos so our
graph went from this to this now we
still had some clunky episodes and we
still do but eventually we built a solid
viewer base now videos get a few hundred
thousand views within the first week and
the good ones hit a million in a month
but what I'm most proud of is the
community the people in the comments who
are so encouraging the fans who buy
Wi-Fi's merchandise which is still
bizarre to me not to me look at his
handsome face that only a mother could
love they leave my mother out of this
she was a saint she'd have to be
wouldn't she at Fair Point that's the
biggest strength of the channel it's not
the writing it's not the production it's
it's Heckle fish no it's not it it's the
audience it's you and I literally mean
you watching this right now because I
know that this video is going to be one
of the lowest performing videos of the
year it doesn't have a click bait title
No catchy thumbnail no fancy production
no mysterious Story the only people
who'll get this far and this video are
the people I've been talking about the
members of our community this past year
was incredible if the next year is only
half as good we're on to something
special and it's because of you that all
this was possible me I'm just along for
the ride
[Music]
so that's a wrap on the year we'll be
back next week with a new story for you
again I can't thank you enough for all
the support this year and special thanks
to everyone who's supporting the white
files on patreon you guys are the ones
who make this channel work original gym
deserves the credit for giving me the
push I needed to launch patreon and the
Discord server and speaking of Discord
thanks to the moderators who made the
community work Victoria Daniel zanithos
lillykins Jacob and Johnny Be Good you
guys are the heart of the channel um
would now be a good time to plug heck of
fish t-shirt it would not yeah I figured
I'd ask now if I time this right I'll be
streaming live later so please come
check it out if not please have a safe
and happy New Year and we'll see you
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
I
happy New Year everybody
[Music]